>>> FIRST ON C, FEDERAL
VESTIGATORS ARE REACHING A
CRITICAL DECISION POINT ON
WHETHER OR NOT TO CHARGE THE
PRESIDENT'S SON, HUNTER BIDEN.
SOURCES TELL CNN NO FINAL
DECISION HAS YET BEEN MADE, BUT
CHARGES COULD INCLUDE ALLEGED
TAX VIOLATIONS AND LYING ABOUT
BUYING A GUN WHEN HE TECHNICALLY
WAS NOT ALLOWED TO BECAUSE OF
HIS ACKNOWLEDGED STRUGGLE WITH
DRUG ADDICTION.
THE CASE IS BEING INVESTIGATED
BY THE U.S. ATTORNEY IN DELAWARE
WHO WAS APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND PRESIDENT BIDEN DID
NOT REPLACE THAT U.S. ATTORNEY
BECAUSE OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
CNN'S KARA SCANNELL AND EVAN
PEREZ HAVE DETAILS.
WHY DO INVESTIGATORS NEED TO
DECIDE SOON ON WHETHER OR NOT TO
CHARGE HUNTER BIDEN?
>> ONE FACTOR PROSECUTORS ARE
CONFRONTING IS THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
THERE ARE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
GUIDELINES UBS BRINGING ANY
POLITICALLY SENSITIVE CASES
AROUND AN ELECTION.
THOSE GUIDELINES INCLUDE THINGS
SUCH AS TAKING ANY SORT OF
OVERTSTEPS LIKE AN INDICTMENT OR
EXECUTING OF A SEARCH WARRANT,
ANYTHING PERCEIVED AS PUTTING A
THUMB ON THE SCALE, THEY TRY TO
AVOID THAT.
CURRENT AND FORMER JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS SAY THAT
DEADLINE IS EFFECTIVELY 60 DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
SO THAT IMPLIES THERE COULD BE A
DECISION SOON ABOUT WHAT STEPS
THEY WANT TO TAKE, OR THEY COULD
DECIDE TO WAIT UNTIL AFTER THE
ELECTIONS IN NOVEMBER.
>> EVAN, PRESIDENT BIDEN, NOT TO
MENTION HUNTER BIDEN, ARE NOT ON
THE MIDTERM BALLOT.
IS THERE ANY INDICATION THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND
MIGHT BUCK THIS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT NORM OR THIS WOULDN'T
BE INCLUDED?
>> WELL, JAKE, WE KNOW ONE THING
ABOUT MERRICK GARLAND, HE IS
GOING BY THE BOOK.
EVERYTHING HE DOES IS BY THE
BOOK.
AND IN THIS CASE, AS YOU POINTED
OUT, HE'S NOT -- HUNTER BIDEN
AND CERTAINLY JOE BIDEN ARE NOT
ON THE BALLOT, BUT WE CAN LOOK
AT PREVIOUS YEARS.
PREVIOUS YEARS WITH
CONGRESSIONAL ELECTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN 2018, WE KNOW
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
BROUGHT CASES IN AUGUST OF THAT
YEAR AGAINST MICHAEL COHEN, WHO
WAS THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
PERSONAL ATTORNEY, AS WELL AS
CHRIS COLLINS WHO WAS A
PROMINENT SUPPORTER OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
HE WAS ON THE BALLOT THAT YEAR.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF FACTORS THAT
THESE PROSECUTORS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO CONSIDER, INCLUDING, OF
COURSE, THAT LOOMING IS THE NEXT
YEAR, THE REPUBLICANS ALREADY
SAY THAT IF THEY TAKE OVER THE
HOUSE, THEY'RE GOING TO DO
INVESTIGATIONS.
THEY'RE GOING TO DO HEARINGS
ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN.
SO THOSE ARE ALL THINGS THAT ARE
WORTH CONSIDERING FOR
PROSECUTORS IN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS.
>> AND KARA, THE INVESTIGATION
STARTED OFF PRETTY BROADLY
INCLUDING POSSIBLE MONEY
LAUNDERING, CAMPAIGN FINANCE,
AND FOREIGN LOBBYING VIOLATIONS.
IT SEEMS LIKE INVESTIGATORS HAVE
NARROWED IT DOWN.
>> YEAH, JAKE.
SOURCES TELL EVAN AND I THAT THE
INVESTIGATORS NOW ARE FOCUSING
THEIR FOCUS ON LOOKING INTO
POSSIBLE TAX CHARGES AND ALSO
POSSIBLE FALSE STATEMENTS
RELATED TO THE PURCHASE OF A
FIREARM BY HUNTER BIDEN.
NOW, THIS IS STILL A FLUID
SITUATION, AND NO FINAL CHARGING
DECISION HAS BEEN MADE.
BUT IT'S FAIRLY COMMON FOR
INVESTIGATORS TO LOOK BROADLY AT
SOMETHING AND THEN FOCUS ON WHAT
THEIR BEST EVIDENCE IS AND WHAT
THEY CAN PROVE BEFORE A JURY.
SO THIS IS STILL SOMETHING THAT
IS BEING DISCUSSED AMONG THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS.
BUT OUR SOURCES TELL US THEY'RE
NEARING A DECISION.
NOW, HUNTER BIDEN, WE SHOULD
NOTE, HAS NOT BEEN ACCUSED OF
ANY WRONGDOING AND HE'S DENIED
ANY WRONGDOING SAYING HE THINKS
ONCE THE INVESTIGATION IS OVER
HE WILL NOT BE CHARGED WITH
ANYTHING.
>> THANKS TO BOTH OF YOU.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH MY PANEL.
PAUL, WHO KNOWS WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN, RIGHT?
BUT ASSUMING THAT HUNTER BIDEN
WERE CHARGED IN AUGUST, WHICH IS
A POSSIBILITY, WITH SOMETHING,
COULD THAT DEPRESS DEMOCRATIC
TURNOUT, YOU THINK?
>> NO.
NO.
I WISH THE GUY WELL.
HE STRUGGLED WITH ADDICTION AND,
YOU KNOW, NOBODY HAS CHARGED HIM
WITH ANYTHING.
BUT THIS HAS BEEN A REPUBLICAN
FIXATION TO NO AVAIL.
THEY HAVE GOT NO POLITICAL GAIN
OUT OF THIS.
I LOOKED UP RON JOHNSON, THE
SENATOR FROM WISCONSIN, A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO, WAS ASKED ABOUT MASS
SHOOTINGS, HE SAID THIS, QUOTE,
BEFORE WE PASS ANYTHING NEW ON
GUNS, LET'S ENFORCE THE LAW WE
ALREADY HAVE.
LET'S START WITH HUNTER BIDEN.
WHAT THE HECK?
SO IT'S A CHALLENGE FOR HUNTER
BIDEN.
I WISH HIM WELL, BUT IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE A POLITICAL ISSUE.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE IF ANYTHING, IT
PROBABLY ENERGIZES DEMOCRATS
BECAUSE IT MAKES THEM THINK IT'S
POLITICAL AND THAT REPUBLICANS
ARE JUST GOING AFTER HIM FOR
THAT REASON.
YOU SAW SOME OF THAT WITH
INVESTIGATIONS INTO HILLARY
CLINTON.
>> AT LEAST WE CAN HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
IS NOT GOING TO INTERJECT
HIMSELF INTO THIS.
HE'S NOT GOING TO TRY TO PUT HIS
THUMB ON THE SCALE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THEY ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
CONDUCT THIS INVESTIGATION
INDEPENDENTL